What's up everyone? Today we are bringing you
another incredible lesson with the
songs of none other than Beyoncé.
It's no surprise that Beyoncé is one of
the most successful recording artists of
all time. In fact, she has sold over 100
million records worldwide. Not only this,
but she is incredibly talented, not only at
singing but also at dancing and acting too.
By the way, in case you're new here, we make
lessons every week to help you learn fast English.
Without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles. In fact,
Andre says that he felt stuck with his English
but our channel cheered him up. So be sure to hit
that Subscribe button and the Bell down below,
so that you don't miss any of our new lessons!
So in this lesson we have taken some of Beyoncé's
best songs to help you learn English slang
and vocabulary. So let's get
straight into today's lesson.
Do you struggle to understand fast speaking
natives? Then I highly recommend our Fluent
with Friends course. In this 48-week course you
will learn with the first seasons of Friends.
You'll receive pdf power lessons every
week, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle Global Community
and so much more! And did you know you can
try it right now for FREE with our 3-Part
Masterclass? All you have to do is click up
here or in the description box below to learn
more and sign up now. We hope to see you there!
If you're enjoying this lesson, then I
highly recommend that you check out our
lesson with Jennifer Lopez next, where you
can learn Advanced English words and slang.
You can click up here or in the
description box below to watch that next.